all right this is from the daily wire
says billionaire Elon Musk will
reportedly gut Twitter with massive cuts
when he takes over getting rid of the
overwhelming majority of the company The
Washington Post reported that musk told
prospective investors that he plans to
get rid of nearly 75 percent of
Twitter's 7 500 workers whittling the
company down to a skeleton staff of just
over 2 000. the report said that even if
the musks even if musk's acquisition of
Twitter somehow does not go through
large cuts are still expected as the
current people running the company plan
to get rid of roughly 25 percent of the
company's staff so they were already
planning on making big cuts of 25
percent
Elon Musk is saying let's triple that
and get rid of 75 the report said that
the plan cuts by Twitter's Executives
helped to explain why the company wanted
to sell to musk once he made the offer
the social media platform had been
fighting musk and Court over his attempt
to cancel the previous buy so we know
about all that so 75 is what their what
their uh what Elon Musk supposedly
is planning to cut I think this is great
news
I don't generally make a habit of
celebrating job loss
um unless it's at Twitter
or if it's at like Planned Parenthood
or if it's anywhere else in big Tech
or if it's in the federal government
so maybe I do make a habit of
celebrating job loss but anyway this is
great news because because
primarily because absolutely gutting the
staff
is the only real way to make the woke
censorship and all of that go away
and this is one of the reasons why the
media when they're reporting on this
they're they're panicking over it
because the weather is not going to be
enough there's going to be misin for
quote unquote misinformation and hate
speech all over Twitter there's not
gonna be enough people there to put out
all these fires
that's exactly the point
you know I've already declared my
intention which I'm which I still intend
on this my intention to go on a
misgendering
spree it's going to be a misgendering
massacre once Elon Musk takes over I'll
just be I'll just be misgendering
everyone
all the time and it'll be great but that
also assumes that the old regime is
actually cleared out
um because if it's not if Elon Musk
takes over and but then almost everyone
else stays in place beneath him then
there's no actual reason to think that
anything changes
and one thing that we know is that it's
very hard
to
change a fundamentally left-wing
institution even from the top
Donald Trump discovered that
and the fundamentally a left-wing
institution in his case was the Federal
Government
but it's very hard to do and the more
people that there are the the bigger the
bureaucracy uh the more difficult it is
so the only way is to go in there and
just clean clean the place out
which fortunately looks like that's what
he is uh
planning to do and that'll do it for
this portion of the show as we move over
to the members block
um hope to see you there if not hope to
at least see you out at the rally today
and if not then then on Monday Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]